so much of your stage presence was you
almost acting not acting living out
exactly how I felt about things ain't in
him early days I mean I've had a lot of
blood problems even our childhood
illnesses whatever and do you only think
I ever found any enjoyment in was
listening to music and reading and so
kind of ready-made for The Sex Pistols
because of that and I just dived into it
I got the chance to write songs about
the society I was living in and I think
I detailed it very accurately this is a
yes it was a very early age for you to
do that and it was it I think it
completely changed the trajectory of
rock pop music completely after the
sections are broken family yeah well it
did let's talk about that there's so
much talk these days about people in
this current administration the new
administration people being worried
about well and and it was worried and
what's interesting can I kind of break
it down really easy I became an American
about three four five years ago right I
can't quite remember I did that because
I believed in Barack Obama and I thought
that that was the way forward
his healthcare thing didn't quite work
out what we all want but there is a
great potential there right now we're
looking at dismantling and and and you
know crazy voodoo monster party but here
it goes I'm now an American I and and
I'm proud to be an American I didn't
realize you wrote I've been John Lydon
I've been Johnny Rotten
now I'm donut bump you'll get it
eventually when you see the shape of the
fella
I'm over here everyone loves Donuts what
a person in America doesn't love Donuts
it's a beanie that's all I've been
offered backstage Donuts and and you
know here spray yeah those are the
things that keep this show alive come
here you don't have to go to CVS or
Walgreens
you